i
[Música]
rocío cabello
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
i
[Música]
ah
a ver
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
cuando vemos alguna película leemos
algún libro o comentamos algo acerca del
holocausto en que pensamos que se nos
viene a la cabeza
pensamos en 2ª guerra mundial nazis y
hitler pero y en música
pensamos en música
realmente es un concepto muy difícil de
relacionar en este contexto pero si hubo
música en el holocausto y tuvo un papel
muy importante más del que imaginamos
llevo años
embarcada en un proyecto de
investigación para descubrir el papel
fundamental que jugó la música durante
la segunda guerra mundial
esta investigación surge a raíz de mi
primera visita al campo de concentración
y exterminio de auschwitz birkenau en
polonia hace aproximadamente unos nueve
años esa primera visita no me dejó
indiferente estuve sin poder dormir bien
durante varias semanas mi mente no era
capaz de asimilar lo que mis ojos habían
visto allí y mi cabeza empezó a
formularse un montón de preguntas
preguntas a las que quise dar respuesta
lo primero que recuerdo nada más
atravesar la puerta del campo principal
es una fotografía con una descripción no
sé si la veis muy bien es una fotografía
de 1941 una fotografía de una orquesta
una orquesta en auschwitz música en un
campo de exterminio la verdad es que me
quedé bastante confundida hoy en día aún
sabiendo lo que ocurrió en ese campo
donde murieron entre un millón y un
millón y medio de personas
el hecho de imaginarme música allí me
descolocó completamente todo estrategia
claro eso es lo que fue el régimen nazi
fue política propaganda y una estrategia
impresionante la música fue parte de ese
proceso también sirvió como instrumento
de organización manipulación y control
pero también fue un instrumento de
salvación y de vida la música salvó
vidas y es lo que he venido hoy a
contaros tenemos retroceder unos años
antes de la creación de auschwitz hitler
asciende al poder
recordemos democráticamente las medidas
llevadas a cabo por el partido nazi
dejan bien claro que los años futuros no
van a ser nada fáciles es imposible
citar todas las atrocidades que preceden
a auschwitz
quizás por decirlo de alguna forma la
creación de trabajo de campos de trabajo
forzado y los guetos pueden ser las más
cercanas pero qué tiene que ver la
música en todo esto el partido nazi
utilizó la música como forma para
persuadir e influenciar a las grandes
masas el partido nazi con la música hizo
sus eventos públicos sus reuniones del
partido sus mítines pretendía organizar
a la gente ante un mismo sentimiento
enaltecer el espíritu y extender por
toda europa los ideales de supremacía
aria
pero los judíos que vivían encerrados en
los guetos tenían música ahí dentro si
era otro método propagandístico
estrategia como os decía al principio
con la creación de orquestas coros
agrupaciones musicales
los alemanes justificaban que los judíos
no eran maltratados vamos a ver hay o
coros hay grupos de música que malo
puede haber dentro de un ghetto no todo
estrategia
repito estrategia que funciona a la
perfección os pongo un ejemplo ghetto de
terezín en república checa 1944 recibe
la visita de la cruz roja danesa y la
cruz roja internacional para esa visita
se llevan a cabo una serie de medidas en
el gueto se pintan los muros se crean
jardines y la orquesta del gueto
interpreta un maravilloso concierto
donde tocan el réquiem de verdi y una
ópera infantil compuesta por un
prisionero del propio gueto la ópera
brundibár
la visita quedó completamente satisfecha
la ópera infantil se llegó a representar
hasta 55 veces dentro del propio gueto
hay una cara muy buena de lo que fue la
música y otra no tan buena recordáis la
foto de la que os hablaba al principio
debemos volver a auschwitz
una orquesta que función tenía una
orquesta en un campo de exterminio
la orquesta tenía varias funciones pero
la principal era acompañar con música a
los prisioneros que salían y entraban a
realizar sus trabajos forzados fuera del
campo los prisioneros debían marchar al
ritmo de la música de la orquesta tocaba
podemos hacer un pequeño experimento por
favor nos podemos poner todos de pie y
comenzar a marchar al ritmo de la música
que está sonando fenomenal vamos a
comenzar a marchar a este ritmo la
orquesta tocaba canciones similares a
éstas en su mayoría marchas militares
las que más le gustaban a los alemanes
eran las marchas militares francesas
eran las más rápidas podemos empezar a
marchar un poco más rápido por favor eso
es fenomenal fenomenal muy bien al ritmo
en la marcha vamos a meternos un poco
más en contexto vamos a trasladarnos a
auschwitz en invierno
de grados bajo cero con un pijama de
rayas' regresando de haber hecho
numerosos trabajos forzados
[Música]
completamente agotados podemos
agarrarnos de un compañero por favor y
apoyar el peso en el cargamos con el
compañero venga vamos a cargar un
compañero eso es cuestan un poco esta es
la situación a la que se enfrentaban la
mayoría de prisioneros que venían
cargando con un compañero desfallecido
realmente me cuesta meterse en este
papel no cuesta imaginarse cómo fue
aquello muchísimas gracias por habernos
prestado esto como he visto por aquí
pues ha habido risas no ha habido un
poco pues de un par de tropiezos por ahí
si yo me lleva a tropezar en público no
sé lo que me lleva a pasar la vergüenza
habéis sido espectacular pero en
auschwitz en 1941 1942 ese mal gesto
hubiese supuesto grandes castigos e
incluso la muerte
numerosas historias de vida y de
salvación he encontrado a lo largo de la
investigación
me encantaría me encantaría citar las a
todas pero es imposible debéis
comprender que más de 6 millones de
víctimas no se pueden resumir en unos
minutos por eso vengo a presentaros tres
historias tres historias de tres mujeres
a las que la música les salvó la vida la
primera de ellas es esther viajar a no
estar bejarano era pianista y en
auschwitz de vez en cuando en los
barracones donde estaba encerrada pues
cantaba alguna canción mozart schubert
hasta que un día se le presentó la
primera oportunidad de vida cuando se
ofrecen voluntarias para ser participe
en la orquesta de mujeres de birkenau
esther era pianista como os he dicho en
la orquesta de birkenau sólo quedaba un
acordeón esther dijo yo me agarra esta
oportunidad e intento hacer lo que sea
pidió unos minutos para calentar
supuestamente y aprender cómo funcionaba
más o menos el instrumento se aprendió
un par de acordes ella recuerda a do
mayor y salió del paso y fue admitida en
la orquesta de mujeres de birkenau la
segunda oportunidad que se le plantea
esther es cuando
enferma y es llevada a la enfermería del
campo hecho que no pasaba con la mayoría
de prisioneros la tercera oportunidad es
cuando el comandante jefe de las ss del
campo conocido por ser lo más cruel y
sanguinario se planta en la enfermería
donde estaba esther y amenaza de muerte
a la enfermera que cuidaba de ella y le
dice que como externo vuelva a retomar
su papel como músico de la orquesta ella
sería fusilado
a las 4 semanas esther volvió a retomar
su papel como acordeonista de la
orquesta hoy en día sigue cantando aquí
la podéis ver y es miembro de un grupo
de rap
ahí lo dejo
la segunda historia que vengo a contaros
es la de helen h trono va en el h trono
va fue deportada a auschwitz con junto
con su hermana y su sobrina allí comenzó
a hacer los trabajos más duros y
forzados que se podían hacer dentro del
campo vio la oportunidad para escaparse
de ahí en formar parte de un grupo de
comando un poco más fácil y lo hizo se
escapó fue descubierta y fue condenada
al campo penal donde hubiese sido
condenada a muerte si no llega a ser
porque ese mismo día se pidieron
voluntarias para cantar en el cumpleaños
de un ss del campo france bunge france
era un ss del campo y esa noche
helen a canto para él
desde el minuto 1 franz se quedó
completamente prendado de ella y
arriesgó su vida desde entonces al
salvar la vida de selena y la de su
hermana arriesgando su propia vida hasta
el fin de la existencia de auschwitz lo
que ocurre es que genera siempre recordó
lo que su padre le había dicho nunca te
olvides de quien eres por eso no
volvieron a verse hasta muchos años
después cuando helen a testificó a favor
de france en el juicio contra éste
liberándole de todos los cargos a los
que se enfrentaban
la tercera historia que vengo a
mostraros es
la historia de alma rossi alma rosé era
la sobrina del compositor gustav mahler
y era una violinista reconocida por toda
europa hasta ser apresada por la gestapo
y deportada a auschwitz
allí fue seleccionada como la directora
de la orquesta de mujeres
con su violín era capaz de atraer a todo
el público que la escuchaba llevó a los
a lo más alto a la orquesta palabras
similares a éstas las que dice simon la
chs que era un violinista de la orquesta
de hombres me encontrado a lo largo de
la investigación
simon las decía como hombres que son
capaces de cometer tantas barbaridades
contra el resto del ser humano son
capaces de llorar escuchando música esto
es lo que ocurría con alma cuando alma
cogía su violín era capaz de hacer
llorar a un ss
y alma por desgracia falleció en el
campo y fue la única persona judía a la
que se le realizó un funeral dentro del
propio auschwitz se le cubrió el cuerpo
con una sábana blanca y se lo llenó de
flores
el ser humano ha mostrado sus peores y
más crueles formas de comportarse pero
por otro lado las más bellas y valientes
es por ello que quiero seguir
descubriendo estas estas historias de
vida y de salvación para seguir dando
voz a aquellas personas que ya no pueden
sino olvidar nunca a todas las víctimas
de la guerra y para reflexionar para que
las imágenes que vemos hoy en día no nos
dejen impasibles
queremos terminar con una obra compuesta
para este propósito salón paz espero que
algún día la música pueda seguir
salvando vidas y por qué no nos salve de
este loco mundo en el que vivimos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
no
y
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
y más
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y